個人的な感想だが
日本の声優が優秀すぎるからなのか
ハリウッド映画の原作とその吹替版の間にいつもちょっとしたギャップがあるように
感じます
僕からするといつもそれをこういうふうに感じます
ただ
な the がっ
raf 姫わーナチュルフレスポ日ベスト今マイコン
ヤンキーにセンターらぽーつ泳い
ピザやだびあさんん
ニャー
主キーホルダー付ワンせ件
はありません
だからいや30入るん
大もしもし
ん大丈夫だよ
最近彼からあんまり連絡来ないんだね
いやーちょっとわかんないなマイケルに電話するといいかもね
うん
あじゃぁ後で送ってもらっていホント
ピザいーでーん
女ちょっと待ってもらってい
ターン大丈夫米
もだった
ざれ
ばいばいばい
なんだ忙しいていたザ
あいつなら連絡来るわけがねえ3年前の銀行強盗でなくなってるからな
しるか本部に当たってくれ
なんだたまーに仕事できるじゃないか
終わったらスミス探偵に送信しろ
長打んじゃねぇ
食事の話をしてる場合か俺を今から大量殺人事件の現場だぞ
スカたねーなー
ハームと倍のアップルで
なんでこんな時に
バーカやめとけ
いやこの状況だと生きて帰れる保証がどこにもないんだなぁ
連合は頼むジェシカに愛してるんだ
まあ演じる
12兄自慢の息子だと伝えてくれ
それから
万が一俺がここで最悪の結末迎えたらお前な感情的になって一人でピザを食うんじゃ
ない
あったなじゃあな
me